Apple's brand-new ipad OS is coming this
fall and it's finally making iPads more
like computers and that's thanks to some
major updates to the files app including
dedicated local storage and external
storage support we've just downloaded
the first developer beta so let's take a
look at everything you can already do
with external storage on the 2018 iPad
pro we just unbox this SanDisk dual USB
flash drive and filled it up with
different files from our Mac what makes
this drive special is because it
features both USB a and USB C so you can
easily transfer files between the iPad
pro and basically any computer will
leave a link to this flash drive down
below plugging it into the iPad pro and
opening the files app we can see the new
drive pop-up in the locations menu and
opening it we see a ton of different
files let's see if we can easily copy
all those files to the iPads local
storage or in other words on my iPad
location tap select select all then tap
move choose on my iPad and let's create
a new folder named USB back up and then
hit copy as you can see our local
storage shows the USB back up folder and
all our files are now in there if you
perform a long press on a folder we get
a bunch of options including compress
which creates a zip file out of it we
can also tap on any file name to quickly
and easily rename it and then if you tap
on the zip file it'll start unzipping it
let's select these files and delete them
but they won't be erased from storage
just yet we have to head down to the
recently deleted section tap select and
tap delete all to fully erase them off
the storage heading back to the flash
drive we can easily open this PDF file
mark it up if we'd like and hit share
from there you can copy the file prints
it or share it any way you'd like
including easily air-dropping it to any
Apple device now let's open this mp4
video file if plays just fine straight
from the USB Drive and even trim it down
to any length in the share menu we could
also save the video to the iPad we also
get options to copy it to luma fusion
but it doesn't seem to work just yet so
let's open luma fusion and see if we can
import the video now that we have it
open
let's open files and split screen by
bringing up the dock and dragging it to
the side
then we can easily drag the video file
into luma fusion and there you go
it's imported and we can now start
editing it we also have some music files
on here in three different formats mp3
m4a and wav and all three play just fine
you can easily scrub through the songs
timeline and even share it using airdrop
and just as easily as a video file you
can import it into luma fusion and edit
it we also added a screen recording we
took on our Mac and although it wouldn't
play within the files app we were able
to import it into luma fusion and it
played back just fine even though it
said this clip isn't fully supported the
beauty of this is that we didn't have to
import them into camera roll however if
we dig into the luma fusion folder in
local storage we'll find those files
copied over and that's because
third-party apps like luma fusion
haven't yet been updated to read
directly from a storage drive but we
expect them to be able to soon heading
back to the flash drive let's check out
some more files these font files are
recognized as fonts but I don't think
we'll be able to do anything with them
since Apple will have their own font
manager within the App Store HTML files
open up just fine so you can view them
as an image and print them from the
share menu
text documents easily open up for
viewing and we'll show you how you can
edit these in just a moment
even XML files will open up for viewing
by whoever wants to which is really
impressive here's an MOV video file from
a finalized YouTube video we made in the
past it works perfectly we also have a
folder filled with some photos they open
up just fine and you can swipe left and
right to view them you can also tap and
hold on one of the photos drag it down
and use the other finger to select some
more photos and then drop them into
local storage there you go you've just
imported photos into the local storage
and as you can see they're nowhere to be
found in the camera roll going back to
the USB Drive we can also view raw
photos but it doesn't seem to show the
full image if you tap into one however
we can tap share and then tap Lightroom
and tap launch Lightroom right now and
there you go it imported the raw photo
and we can start editing after finishing
the edit you can tap share save to files
and it doesn't seem like saving to the
flash drive is available yet in this app
but we can still save it to local
storage as you can see our new
Edda is saved and interestingly we can't
find the original raw photo
it wasn't imported it was actually
editing off the flash drive and it's
missing from the camera roll as well we
can now go back to the files app grab
that edited photo and transfer it to the
flash drive now here's a Microsoft Excel
file that easily opens up for reading
but if we open the numbers app we can
open that excel file which creates a
duplicate numbers file and we can start
editing it once finished tap share and
then we can choose to save to files and
even export it straight to the USB Drive
and there it is in the files app along
with the duplicated numbers file here's
a Microsoft Word document it opens up
just fine for reading but if we open the
Pages app and go into the flash drive we
can open that Word document and start
editing and just like before we can
export it straight into the flash drive
now here's perhaps the coolest part we
can go into Safari search for a
PowerPoint file tap on it and hit
download we'll see the progress and the
new download manager from there we can
tap to open it to find it within the
files app go to Cloud Drive downloads
and there it is to make it even better
let's open up the keynote app and find
that file there you go we're editing
this PowerPoint and again we can save it
directly to the flash drive and there it
is on the flash drive and going back to
the local storage there are no signs of
any other original files we edit in so
we were editing everything directly off
the flash drive now here's something
that everybody's been waiting for you
can now backup your photos directly to a
flash drive or other external storage go
to photos select the ones you want to
backup or tap select all within an album
then tap share tap save to files tap on
your flash drive or hard drive make a
new folder called photos backup in tap
save
heading back to the files app you'll
find that your photos successfully
backed up
there's no eject button anywhere so you
can unplug your drives at any time
without worry
we also tested out a SATA SSD using a
SATA to USB adapter and then Apple's USB
C to USBA adapter and it worked
perfectly fine just like the flash drive
now we tried an SD card that we use for
our cameras and it was named error name
we started running into issues like
error messages popping up when we tried
to transfer files
so it seems like sdcard support is a bit
buggy right now we then connected our
Sony camera and we got the same error
message so we'll have to revisit support
for these devices later but overall
we're extremely impressed with what we
can already do in the first beta of iPad
at Wes and we're very excited for the
rest of our favorite third-party apps to
get updated to support Apple's new file
system without having an import into
camera role anymore
again we'll leave a link to this awesome
flash drive down below and if you want
to see the full guide to the new files
app and iPad OS including iPads with a
lightning connector it's at that like
button click up there to subscribe so
you don't miss out thanks for watching
and we'll see you in the next video
[Music]